she spent the first few years of her
career
chasing somali pirates
so please welcome someone who i met
where i didn't think i met please
welcome sarah nice so where did we go
in fact i'm pretty sure that i i like
cold emailed you and basically was like
i think you worked for the minnesota
vikings am i correct yes
and i'd love to chat and i'd love your
help with my fantasy football lineup so
we met and we had like coffee somewhere
this part i remember we did have like
coffee somewhere in nomad um yes and i'm
like
99.9
sure that happened before like probably
subsequently encountering each other at
one of those dinners but
this is my recollection of it and i
still want your help with my fantasy
football i would give you help but mike
bam you spoke earlier he's probably
gonna be even more helpful than i am but
i'll i'll give you my mediocre help
compared to him
nice my my strategy has been like just
get as many back up to running backs as
possible because like
covet injuries these all seem inevitable
exactly
so thank you i'm going to jump off stage
and you can go on thank you
cool
see you soon
okay
um thanks again jared it looks like
everybody can see my screen um so i'm
going to start with two warnings the
first is that um the title of the talk
is like completely misleading um today
is not the day that i'm going to rant
against machine learning i'll probably
save that for another day but i do want
to talk about you know causal inference
and
why it's not reaching its potential as
well as perhaps like how startups can
help it reach its potential
uh the next warning is that like this
talk is not going to be technical um as
jared mentioned i used to be a data
scientist i'm not a data scientist
anymore um kind of like um what was that
that like sara bareilles song back in
the day that they're like i'm not gonna
write you a love song and like people
thought it was about her boyfriend um
but actually it was about her like
producer or
i don't know something like that so when
jared reached out to me i was like sure
i'll speak but i'm not gonna write you a
technical talk um i will talk about
startups and markets that's what i do
nowadays
so on that note
what do i do
nowadays
uh so
oh i'm sarah catanzaro i'm a partner at
amplify partners and we're an early
stage venture capital firm uh we invest
in technical tools and platforms and i
specifically invest in the dnml stack
so
a lot of people probably think that like
i spend most of my time meeting with
startups uh running diligence processes
negotiating terms etc etc etc in fact uh
that's not really true i probably only
do about like one to four deals a year
uh but i spend a lot of my time working
on investment hypotheses and the these
hypotheses will kind of guide my next
set of investments and also in some
cases define like kind of the guidance
that i give to my existing portfolio
so you know i do i do seed in series a
investing which means i'm typically like
the first or second check in
and you know most companies most
startups won't ipo until like at least
seven to ten years so effectively what
i'm doing is is you know trying to
predict like what is going to happen in
the next seven to ten years a large part
of that is actually looking at like what
are the problems that data teams face
today what are the solutions that
they're implementing to solve those
problems and what either like new
problems are those solutions going to
engender or what what new opportunities
will those engender
and that's how i kind of got interested
in potentially investing in causal
inference this is still all really rough
investment hypotheses it's like a very
fuzzy art uh i went from doing like
rigorous data science to like
combination of like intuition and
reasoning from first principles so
that's my like third caveat i guess
um but yeah let's talk about like what's
happening now so basically what i'm
seeing is that like data teams have had
this kind of like come to jesus moment
they're realizing like finally that like
both bi and ai initiatives they're
they're not going to succeed until data
teams invest in in data quality and and
this is great like this has been my like
rallying cry for like the past decade
like do something about data quality and
it's finally happening and you're seeing
you know companies uh bring on both
people as well as invest in tools that
are really focused on on integrating
data from disparate systems uh building
like core data models within the the
data warehouse and then like even
testing and monitoring those core data
models again like this is super awesome
it's not just awesome for you like it's
awesome for me too because uh we're also
seeing kind of billion dollar companies
emerge uh in this space so you know as
an example like dbt which is designed to
do like dimensional data modeling within
the data warehouse it is now a
multi-billion dollar company great
expectations which enables you to kind
of write tests on your python data
pipelines um also a billion dollar
company and this is like super exciting
great for investors great for
practitioners um
but this market is becoming increasingly
crowded so like frankly i don't think
like this is the right time to start a
company focused on like data quality
monitoring for example
um
there are just so many market
participants they're all venture backed
they all have you know war chest filled
with like millions of dollars and so so
uh
what i've been thinking about is like
what happens next
i mean effectively like
if your team has seamless access to
like well-documented well-tested
well-monitored data sets what is it that
you do differently like ultimately like
just having good data is not going to
produce impact for companies but like
something else might
uh or something else in addition to
having good data might
so how i've been thinking about this is
that like having good data really lets
you do two things um it allows you to
answer existing questions better
um but it also allows you to answer
better questions
uh the the way that i reason about this
often is that like
bi helps companies answer questions
about what's happening now
um ai helps companies predict what might
happen in the future
but causal inference actually helps
companies answer questions about what
they should do and those are often like
the most important questions
uh so
as a little bit of an aside like
as a vc i also attend a lot of board
meetings and sometimes like the board
meetings are like just reporting but
more often than not like the aim of the
board meeting is to discuss the
strategic issues that are going to kind
of like make or break the company that
will enable them to raise their next
round of financing effectively or will
you know lead to their like short-lived
acquisition you know something like that
and in fact like the questions that
we're discussing the matters that we're
discussing during these these board
meetings like they're often they're
often questions about causal effects
um
these are the most important questions
that that companies have to answer so if
companies like want to become data
driven if they want to embark on like
data driven decision decision-making
then they need to figure out a causal
inference
but i think you know the problem that i
see today is that companies neither have
the tools nor the people
um to really do causal inference
effectively so they're they're they're
asking and attempting to answer causal
questions but they're not really doing
it well and they're not doing it well
because they just don't have like the
capabilities and
competencies uh
again like not really rigorous science
but but to provide some sort of like
quote anecdotal evidence of this
i looked at like causal inference and
machine learning on linkedin and in
github um i think on linkedin like a
people search for
machine learning returns something like
3.2 billion people
and the same search for causal inference
returned like what was it about ten
thousand so so that's like pretty crazy
to me
um similarly when i searched uh for
repos on on github machine learning
returned like nearly 350 000 results and
causal inference returned about 1200.
and and look like this is not like real
evidence of anything
but you know i think it does underscore
the problem that like we want to ask
questions about why things are happening
and what we can do about it like these
are critical to a business but we don't
know how
so this is kind of like where i'm at
like i think that like with all of these
investments going into building better
data sets we're going to see companies
shift focus to like doing causal
inference more effectively
um i wanted to i wanted to get like
feedback on this hypothesis so you know
obviously again like it did this in a
really scientific way and i posted it on
twitter uh
interestingly like people almost
unanimously agreed that causal inference
would have a bigger impact on industry
than machine learning but they also
acknowledged that like it's hard and too
hard to do right now and that's you know
potentially crippling its adoption
so
i have like
the
beginnings of this investment hypothesis
about about causal inference um
but i need to like get more specific
than that to like start trying to find
companies or like trying to find people
who will start companies
so
i've just started like brainstorming
about what types of tools what types of
platforms will actually enable companies
to do causal imprints more effectively
um and i've been thinking about this by
kind of reasoning about what i'm seeing
in the ml ecosystem uh now the the the
ecosystem of tools and platforms in
machine learning i would say is probably
a bit more advanced than in causal
inference and
there was a hype cycle that's what hype
cycles do
uh but instead of just kind of like
reasoning about this through the lens of
machine learning also got some feedback
from
a much smarter people uh people like
sean taylor bryant chen michael kaminsky
jeff wong mike young so if any of you
are out there thank you for your
comments
but let's dive into this so
now the first thing that i think is
going to happen is that we will see
companies invest more in these tools and
platforms that first enable them to do
experimentation and then help them
accelerate the pace of experimentation
and kind of advance their
experimentation methodologies so so like
maybe why experimentation and not
observational causal imprints
so my my colleague sunil he talks about
this like stubbed your toe problem
um maybe it's not even a problem but
essentially like what we see happening
when any new technical paradigm emerges
is that a company see that paradigm and
instead of thinking about like what are
the foundations that i need to do this
effectively or like how can i like prove
this out in a narrowly scoped way
instead they say like
let's do the hardest thing possible
um
so that's basically what we saw happen
in in machine learning maybe like three
to five years ago uh instead of starting
small a bunch of companies hired teams
of like phd research scientists and
asked them to build online deep learning
systems and in fact a set of startups
also emerged around that same time that
basically said like hey sears or like
i don't know shell like we're going to
help you build online deep flirting
systems even though you might not even
need them um
so
not surprisingly like these initiatives
they they failed um
but i think that that failure was
important in that you know it forced
companies to kind of
re-evaluate what they were doing forced
them to step back and start smaller
so so the same companies started to
implement simpler models you know
implements like linear regression on
tabular data and that really had like
two important effects the first was that
by doing things in a more minimally
scoped way
uh they were able to really develop a
better understanding of like what
foundations they needed
of you know some of the either data
issues or or systems architecture issues
that really had to be resolved before
they could do ml effectively um
the other thing is that like
they got some wins under their belt like
they were able to implement simple
models that worked they were able to
demonstrate results and get more
executive buy and therefore they were
able to kind of amass bigger budgets for
these initiatives
and why this is important at least from
like a vc perspective was like this
created opportunity now you had these
companies who had seen that ml could be
effective um it could kind of like move
the needle for their business but they
also had a clear understanding of
their kind of architectural and and data
needs
um and an appetite to find startups that
would address those needs so i guess
like tlbr is like if you're going to
build a tool kind of associated with a
new technical paradigm
including something like causal
inference like
wait for your customers to like stub
their toe and kind of like come crawling
back to you because that that that's
basically what we saw happening in the
ml space
um
and you know since that's happened we've
seen kind of the rise of new ml tools
and platforms many of which are really
focused on addressing either those like
uh data management issues you see
companies like like techton they're
they're building a feature store
um
or like integrating with other elements
or components of the tech stock so so
ocuml is a company within our portfolio
they help users deploy like any model on
any hardware backend
um the other thing that you saw too is
that like the appetite to build like
online deep learning models it didn't go
away
um and so in fact you know companies
also sought tools that would help them
make progress from these simpler models
to you know things like transformers so
now now there's like a lot of traction
around companies like hugging face
so you know i i think we are starting to
see and we'll see more of
unfortunately or fortunately i don't
know uh a similar similar phenomena in
in causal inference there will be there
are some data teams that are like just
rushing into observational causal
inference um
and you know
maybe this is controversial maybe it's
not but like i think most of them will
fail
am i supposed to say that
i can say whatever i want because none
of you can react right now
um
yeah so so you know my expectation is
that
uh these data teams that that start
their causal inference journey with
observational causal and friends will
probably fail
um but they might then you know try
again with like much simpler experiments
like things like two sample
a b tests
um and through those tests i think like
they will similarly gain a better
understanding of their data and system
requirements as well as like get some
wins under their belt so that they can
increase executive buy-in for
experimentation and ultimately no causal
inference
so what is the the kind of opportunity
specifically now as this process unfolds
i think we'll see more startups that are
really focused on addressing again some
of the kind of data issues associated
with experimentation
um you're already starting to see this
as it relates to like the demand for
log enabled analytics if you're going to
run experiments you have to trust your
events
right now maybe you shouldn't trust your
events
uh i think we're starting to see this
too with like metrics management and
enabling like fast uh slice and dice on
data that might exist in the data
warehouse
but beyond kind of the the like data and
systems like things i think we're also
going to see a need for uh tools and
platforms that just help companies like
run more experiments without uh
compromising on analytical rigor and
then ultimately move on to kind of more
advanced uh
like both assignment regimes as well as
uh experimentation methodologies so so
we'll go from you know those two sample
a b tests to maybe like heterogeneous
treatment effects maybe even contextual
bandits um and i do think like startups
can play an important role in that
journey there's also a lot of random
memes in here i was going to talk about
like machine learning and causal
inference and then i decided not to but
i didn't have time to replace the memes
so i hope you enjoy them anyway
um oh yeah so
um i did put my money where my mouth is
um
i do believe strongly that like we're
going to see kind of this tidal wave of
companies embracing experimentation in
the next decade or so and as such i
invested in an experimentation platform
called epo you should all check it out
at get appo
i can never remember domains anymore
so what else
here um
i've been thinking about like
when we see a new technical paradigm
like relatively new technical paradigm
um
what are these sets of technologies that
actually accelerate the adoption of it
and you know initially i was thinking
that it came down to kind of three
things uh model evaluation um enabling
more rapid iteration and facilitating uh
interaction with
others other stakeholders within the
company but as i was thinking about kind
of like those three pillars i realized
that they all kind of collapse into one
thing
which is
enabling more rapid iteration
and i think there's both an acute need
as well as like a market opportunity for
for tools that enable companies to
iterate more rapidly on their causal
models and that do so by both
facilitating or accelerating the pace of
development um but also
enabling iteration by helping us
understand what's working what's not
um and you know facilitate collaboration
thereby uh
allowing us to get feedback from other
types of stakeholders
so how did this play out in a ml well i
mean like just go look at ml ops it's
it's you know attracting like a ton of
investment um which it didn't attract so
when when the ml hype cycle like first
uh really started started uh kind of
peaking maybe like 2014 2015.
um i think what happened was like some
companies
uh successfully deployed their first
model and they got kind of like hooked
on it like new modeling techniques they
they can be like a drug you do it once
and you do it well and then you're like
oh man gotta do that more and not just
more but you know faster and in order to
do like more and faster you often need
tools associated with operations
so you know how has this played out in
ml well i think like we see it playing
out in a couple of domains one is higher
level modeling frameworks and those that
are really designed to eliminate the
need for glue code as well as uh just
thinking about like low level
implementation details um
the other is distributed trading like if
you have to wait for things then you're
not going to work as effectively and
that that's kind of a problem when you
have you know
ml scientists that are paid like 500 000
a year you don't want them
waiting for their model to train
um
model evaluation and monitoring as i
mentioned earlier i think is key to
iterating because you need some way of
understanding like what is working what
is not working what is working better
than than something else and then
finally i think you know these tools
that that really focus on enabling data
scientists to build user facing
applications help facilitate
communication with other teams such that
like you have other other guidance on on
how you might iterate
so i think we're going to see again
something similar happen in causal and
friends where now once companies start
running more and more sophisticated
experiments they're going to want tools
to build
better causal models faster
the clearest need to me honestly is for
like higher level modeling frameworks um
i was reading a blog post from like
stitch fix recently where they developed
you know some sort of like wrapper
around causal impact that like leveraged
higher level abstractions um
if if you know companies are like
building wrappers around things
we probably need just easier to use
frameworks uh that that's
my general observation so so i do think
that there's a pretty clear like white
space
um in terms of like
easy
to use modeling frameworks especially
those that that can provide a more
unified way of
specifying like different
models for causal effects
um computational efficiency like for a
while i didn't get this when when i saw
it happening in in ml i'm like well like
these teams their their budgets just
keep increasing and increasing so like
why does distributed training matter
and i didn't realize that it it mattered
until i i i started talking to various
research scientists and they're like it
matters because i can work more things
move faster um
and i think again like the same is is
actually true in in causal inference
like you want to move to
heterogeneous treatment effects and and
other types of like more advanced
modeling techniques but these are really
computationally and memory expensive um
and what computationally and memory
expensive translates to is just like
slow and
costly
um netflix actually put out a white
paper maybe a year ago maybe less than a
year ago on a domain that they're
calling a computational causal inference
and they put forth like a couple of
suggestions on how we can make causal
inference models more computationally
efficient and i think that this is like
a pretty exciting domain
and the last one which almost made me
like bow out of this talks i'm like
maybe i'm just totally wrong here
because if we can't figure this out like
then it's doomed um
i really do believe that the ability to
compare and validate machine learning
models has helped unlock its success and
like for that reason you actually do see
like a lot of tools focused on like what
they call experiment tracking it's
always confusing because it doesn't mean
a b testing it basically just means like
looking at different versions of your
model in the associated metrics uh but
not in production um
you know things like ml flow metaflow
weights and biases replicates like
they're there there are dozens of these
now um
but they both facilitate iteration and i
think also help build like
organizational trust in those models
even though the model metrics don't
often end up giving you a complete view
of what's going to happen in production
um
there's some sort of like i don't know
weird psychology going on there
and
i don't know if it's possible to to like
validate causal models effectively um
that said i'm a vc so i get to like just
sit here and be like this is something
that one of you should build um
and maybe it's not possible and and you
know that that's
what it is
um
in the meantime though i think that like
the way that i often see companies using
at least like observational causal
inference today is that they're they're
effectively using it as a way to
generate like a set of potential
interventions and then they're they're
using you know a b testing to actually
like validate um their their causal
models or perhaps not actually but
whatever it is
so
um some of you might have seen this
slide in sean taylor's talk on uh when
and why to use causal inference a couple
of months ago
uh sean you know certainly pointed to
the fact that like there are significant
investments happening uh
in the ml space right now
uh particularly you know around around
these areas of ml training and model
storage and serving um because like
predicting things is is important to
companies
but i wanted to present real venture
capitalist mode
so
the ml space it's it's also just super
duper crowded and like to be honest i
think we'll still see new entrants
because like most of those tools suck um
but
if causal inference is going to have a
bigger impact on industry that also
means that there's going to be bigger
opportunities to you know make that that
possibility a reality so
uh if you are building one of these
tools you know
call me email me i'm sarah
amplifypartners.com and with that
i'm off
thank you very much sarah
that was that was really great i love
all the uh um chirping at sean taylor
and chris alban that was all that was
really all pretty awesome so thank you
very much for that excellent talk